Andrew Tate the most Googled man on
Earth last year who I don't know where
this guy came from
he seemed to pop out of nowhere which
always makes me suspect okay always
makes me a little bit skeptical and
makes people seem suspect to me but my
producers one time this you got to watch
this guy Andrew Tate so I did I reacted
to some of his videos and I said you
know he's saying things
that contradict the the established
liberal Dogma
so for that I guess
he ought to be applauded or at least we
ought to entertain him but he's also
saying things that seem pretty
degenerate and he isn't he a pimp
doesn't he run a weird sex online
business and that's not good that's not
conservative at all that should be that
should be discouraged
so then Andrew take gets arrested for
apparently running a criminal sex
trafficking ring
and some people on the right have rushed
to his defense
I don't I don't really know what the
defense is I mean the defense could be
he's not being arrested because he's a
sex trafficker he's being arrested
because the libs hate him yeah that
could be true I mean they let Epstein
operate with impunity for years they
don't go after the sexual criminals on
their own side
and they promote sex work as real work
so they they don't sincerely believe
that sex trafficking is a problem but
nevertheless the question is did he do
these things did this guy commit crimes
and there's a video that's just come to
light of Andrew Tate bragging that his
whole business was a scam here's maybe
this is a bit bad here's where the
famous would start so it'd be good like
I had a lot of girls who worked for me
and the best was like the ukrainians or
the Russians it was amazing because they
get some guy fall in love that arranged
today to meet all this
ah I need a visa okay get Visa I need
money for a Visa
okay how much is visas nine hundred
dollars no but it's not 900 because I
went to the Embassy they think I'm a
risk and I need a return flight there
and back and I need a hotel I need to
have spending money in my bank account
they won't let me come how much you need
all right 10 grand booms 10 G's perfect
thanks wow go to the Embassy take a
picture outside the MC Boom come back
they rejected my Visa they said we have
to wait two weeks after two weeks
they'll give it to me okay baby boom two
more weeks of tips boom boom boom boom
because now I think it's gonna right
things to get the girls now he's
spending more than never two weeks two
weeks two weeks two weeks come
some other problem
whether it's Visa whatever whatever we
make up some [ __ ] right all these
only fans chicks can learn from you man
people people watch three only fans
tutorials yeah people who people would
say why did those girls work for you
because the girls would work for me and
at 50 because it was 50 50 would make
millions per month if they work for
themselves they make nothing I was the
best in the game me and I had a whole
team of staff
now one thing you always have to ask
yourself with online self-help Guru
promoter guys like this is are they
telling the truth and we have no reason
to believe that Andrew Tate is telling
the truth because the thing that he is
talking about is how he's a liar
so if you present yourself in public as
a liar then
I can't believe you in fact I can't even
believe any specific claim of you lying
and scamming because you might though
you are dishonest in other ways and
claiming to be dishonest you you may
actually be being truthful or dishonest
about being dishonest you see how it
gets very confusing but but if this part
is true
and he's the best in the effing game and
I'm scamming all these guys then isn't
that fraud
isn't that a crime
isn't that should we really be surprised
that you get arrested
and even if you say well there's plenty
of scammers plenty of fraudsters plenty
of pimps out there they don't get
attacked by the liberal regime right but
you're you've made a name for yourself
attacking all these liberal orthodoxies
meanwhile you're bragging about all the
crimes that you're committing so you're
just showing your neck to your enemies
not very good stuff in any case none of
this particularly virtuous or worth
emulating I strongly suspect this is the
most disturbing story that I have read
in weeks
if if you've got little kids listening
right now maybe just skip ahead a minute
or two
last Friday 11 people appeared before
the high court in Glasgow accused of
operating a satanic cult which abused
two young girls and a boy
who were allegedly forced to engage in
Rich witchcraft rituals and subjected to
sexual and violent abuse by members of
the group
the court heard testimony
that the two young girls and the young
boy had been forced to kill animals use
a Ouija board or a similar sort of tool
quote to call on spirits and demons in
witchcraft ceremonies the children were
then forced into performing satanic
seances including drinking blood and
eating a heart
one of the alleged girl victims was
reported to have been locked in a fridge
a freezer a microwave in an oven in an
attempt to kill her okay that's the
disturbing stuff you can you can
raise the volume back up again if you're
listening with young children obviously
and
insanely disturbing story
but the
the point of the story that is going to
be discussed if it is discussed at all
in the liberal media is that there was
this pedophile ring and they abused
children sexually
that part
is actually the easiest part to
understand
it's easy for people in our modern
liberal decadent age to recognize that
that sex is a powerful motivator and
some people are perverts and and people
can commit sex crimes that part it's
disturbing to anybody with even a shred
of a conscience but it's it's at least
easy to understand
the part that's very difficult for
people to understand in our modern
liberal scientistic age
is the satanic
witchcraft
occult ritual of it all that part people
have a really hard time getting
they say look I understand how a pervert
could want to commit a sexual crime
why the hell they pull out a Ouija board
why were they doing weird witchcraft
stuff why were they calling up D that
can't be real
that doesn't
the hard part to understand isn't the
pedophile stuff it's the satanic stuff
because even the libs even the people
who are trying to normalize pedophilia I
suppose perhaps especially the people
who are trying to normalize pedophilia
and and refer to pedophiles as minor
attracted persons and all the rest of it
they believe in pedophilia everybody
believes that exists
half of the people around today maybe
more do not believe that Satan exists
I always go back to this amazing
interview in New York Magazine in 2011 I
think it was between some young
know-nothing liberal reporter and
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia the
conservative and
somehow Heaven and Hell came up
and the Reporter Goes do you believe in
heaven and hell
and he goes yeah
and she goes that's got to be awful
scary to live in a world with hell
and he goes you know in a theatrical
whisper he says I even believe in the
devil
she goes well boy you got to be shaking
in your boots believing in the devil he
goes do you know how out of touch you
seem
do you realize
that people throughout all of history
have believed in the devil
do you realize that many more
intelligent people than you or I
believe in the devil
and she didn't know what to say
I always go back to Hamlet
there are more things in Heaven and
Earth Horatio and are dreamed of in your
philosophy and I can't help but notice
when when you read these stories of the
pedo sex rings that we were all told
were total conspiracy theories until
they keep being proven again and again
and again including some of the most
prominent wealthy powerful people in the
world
I you can't call it a crazy conspiracy
theory after the Jeffrey Epstein stuff
came to light but I can't help but
notice it always seems to involve
something more than just the physical
body
you look at Jeffrey Epstein's weird pedo
Island there's this bizarre Pagan
Egyptian temple looking thing there
you look at the cases of sexual abuse in
ever in religious communities in
non-religious communities it always
seems to involve weird occult rituals
the stories one hears about this from
people who've been convicted of it
very often goes back to Satan I wonder
why that is wonder why that is
why does it always keep coming back to
the same sort of imagery maybe it's
because many more intelligent people
than you and I have believed in the
devil you know the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign